bien
et
si c'est la maison verte
dans les rêves
centre watson
Ouais
li
Oui oui
dans de nombreux cas, c'est plus nous patxi lazcoz
et
si c'est comme ça
Ouais
punaise de lit aussi simple
et
Ce jour
C'était un degré d'être comme ça, je veux un monde
Venir et on ne sait jamais c'est évident que
mon intention amour
et a donné crédit
ce
indicateur franc
dans
augmenter
la gloire de kenita leur est présentée
et les migrants chiliens ont été vus de front
En raison de la taille du présent
Ouais
mon intention est d'y aller ce soir mais c'était
arrêt
bien qu'il soit intact
Je pensais que je venais d'un moment de ta vie mon
ombre du soleil
toi
limité
les amis les questions
pour que
que mon père tire déjà pour chanter